thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys where we have Colleen with
us today
hello hello hello there's something that
uh hopefully all of us can weigh in on
what was it like
being prom King
you know what
there's only one person here that can
actually answer this question let me on
fire
you smell like I don't know if any of us
were the popular kids but this guy over
here I could only dream of it [__] I'll
be [__] throwing pedals down for the
prom King's [__] car on the football
field I don't even know where to begin
with that like how do you even I was the
nerd that held the cape for the king
yeah what it feels like to get my ass
kicked every day for being a loser
really yeah I can tell you that too what
the [__] you're whipping everybody's
asses bar no yeah I feel like you were
you talking about your pumpkin can I
tell you how like how stupid it's broken
that's so crazy
we're sitting around did you know that
you were like in the running no were you
nominated oh how do you know how do you
like and did you have to make posters no
right it was it was it was can I tell
you this this is how it happened we can
you try the version where you glorify it
though yeah well people are sitting next
to royalty right now I can't either dude
you do it in a German accent no I can't
okay but anyways so we get to the
[__] prom or whatever and it was at a
food court
at the California Science Center or
something like that dude McDonald's
arches was right in the middle of the
[__] place this guy is lowering the
quality so bad it's just I'm just
telling truth that's all I think was in
480p
it was 360 feet thank you but we we pull
up and then people are like checking
their tickets at the [__] ticket
booth or whatever the [__] right you
have to get it the summer wind was
blowing the breeze again yeah yeah and
then and then there was there was like a
there was like a piece of paper that
people were filling out I didn't I
honestly didn't look at it oh so they
fill it out with at the prom that's how
they did it okay and then everybody was
like announcing who the [__] the person
was and they called my name and but that
means her name was already like on the
ballot though yeah but you got nominated
well they weren't paying attention when
everybody was voting for you or that
your name was on every single piece of
paper there so they I could not remember
why are you popular when you don't like
people that's not what it was they came
up to me they're like hey we're gonna
your name is on the ballot and I was
like yeah all right cool I was like yeah
okay and then because there was like
four other dudes they were all the
homies right but they were like they
were all very popular so your whole
group was the coolest kids I wasn't part
like I know what happened I'll say this
everyone in our everyone in our class
got along with everybody so like the
jocks were cool with the little gang
bangers and then the little so what were
you then I was like I was like it was a
water polo jock I would float around
dude you're a gang banging water polo
job I know what it I know exactly what
happened I know all the jocks he's the
Down Syndrome guy that they made prom
King because all the jocks the jocks
wanted to make fun of him that's what
happened and then it was a they put the
crowd they voted the most the least
popular guy and then it went viral dude
so they could laugh at him
that's exactly what happened bro no way
this can be the problem this is so crazy
we're gonna fill this up for 20 minutes
so he's saying Nick Nick's like the the
[__] blind person that plays
basketball that on that Viral clip where
everybody has to stay super quiet and
they're using the meter stick to tap the
[__] they voted you prom King to like
how it was a blowout so they're like all
right let him play get it to help your
self-esteem it's like a Make-a-Wish yeah
it was a Make-a-Wish no they did it for
real though he's like the he's like the
big girl that won the beauty pageant
because everybody felt bad it was like
Carrie they wanted to pick on me and
they threw blood on me no real but it
was like they really liked you that much
huh uh dude I don't that's a crazy
question that's a load of questions I
think Nick's a very likable dude and he
gets along with everybody
I'm painting he went to all those
different groups that was campaigning to
be prompted you guys make sure you vote
for me this super promise science club
Nick's got an announcement guys a bunch
of you got the whole Key Club making you
buttons and [__] yeah I was like vote
for me vote for Nick outside of prom
King were you a senior stand out in the
yearbook a senior standout what does
that mean like you're like most likely
to succeed best smile or best physique
or random [__] like that
I remember
no I I think I I think I just got along
with all the groups of people your
hoodie literally says the Blessed ever
this is Max Holloway
this is his mind I don't see Nick making
anybody mad or like people hating him
you see him as a Down syndrome
yeah lovable like thousands of people
are so lovable they're like they're like
human golden retrievers they're like the
best in the world I think if you ask the
people I went to high school with they
would also see me the same way they're
like oh yeah Nick was the he was a
special needs kid that everybody felt
sorry for okay no let's be real though
how did you get your name onto the
ballot and why I I can honestly tell you
I don't know I swear to God I I think it
would I really don't know maybe so
naturally cool and don't care that
people can feel that and they're like oh
Nick is the coolest right that's a
better narrative I honestly don't right
now dude I don't know how they picked it
and it was it was a surprise it was a
surprise it's like Jon Snow the king
that doesn't want it yeah
that's who he is so who was prom queen
his auntie uh were you at tip at the
time the person yeah but they didn't let
her be the queen no because it was the
person that was was this girl I grew up
with actually this Filipino girl my name
is Christy
um and she was like the class president
she held fine wow you and she's an
actual Queen she have a crush on you she
was classy no you know what was was she
mad no what was that was she mad that
her boyfriend was in the her boyfriend
was some guy that was like an older
actually I think she married her her
High School's boyfriend his name is yeah
yeah they actually by school yeah yeah
his whole school's like the success
stories yeah but
um no no she I grew up with her I knew
her since we were in like second grade
and [__] like we grew up together and we
weren't like the bestest of friends but
we were always cool you know but it was
definitely one of those things where
like oh they're like all right now you
guys dance and then we gotta dance with
each other and then both of them yeah we
were it was hella awkward I was like um
and then she was like should we just go
dance with our guys now we're like okay
yeah and then we just like broke off and
then did Tiff get mad at you I can't
believe you [__] danced with that
[__] husky she she knows Christy too
so it was like it was like a crazy yeah
it wasn't that big of a thing you guys
didn't go like let's touch that [__]
egg roll what yeah you're in the
chickens together
a little bit of this nah but it was it
was so random and it it came out of that
field I swear to God so uh when they
were like and prom King is
dick Nunn what how did you feel during
that moment yeah embarrassed did they
give you this brown yeah did they give
you the cape
and then a spotlight is like searching
the room and then finds you and they're
like oh snap was that was there a photo
of it printed out there's gotta be
that's like a big moment for the school
that's a big moment for the entire
senior class you know how many incoming
freshman dudes are probably there just
[__] their pants going man I hope one
day you better not be lying because that
[__] probably already has it
dude
it's already on the JK social media
right now you got in contact with your
old high school buddies and they all
come outside yeah
to redo that dance oh God can I bring up
Christy because I don't even we didn't
have like prompts so I don't know do
they take I got kicked out bro I don't
know what you talking about yeah
it was it was it was very like it was
very weird do they take like a official
photo and stuff I don't know uh no they
did yeah
so because pictures that I could only
remember is just a picture of me and
Tiff that was it oh wow you guys didn't
have your
earbuds okay because they would have to
do like months in advance right yeah but
yeah so what about you guys what the
[__] I never been a prom it's so
crazy
I never been a prom why do we keep
talking about this one Nick just because
he's uncomfortable yeah
it came up it came up a few videos ago
that he was prom King well this guy just
brought it up and we were joking about
how like he um we were like what you're
a problem King and then we were joking
that he's always wanted to bring it up
but there was never a good time
scenarios I wouldn't
acting like so we were Royals you guys
did did you guys go your your school
dances and Proms and things like that I
went to Bishop ahmad's prom but I didn't
we didn't have San Gabriel didn't have a
problem
they have Banquets yeah they Banquets
yeah and there was no because there's no
dancing at the church bro there's no
like award for like the best anything
it's like they're non-competitive I
would say keppel's prom that's kind of
lame though it's oh problems like proms
dances proms are lame well I think like
it depends it all depends on the high
school so keppel wasn't very like
um TV high school but I pictured a big
ass High School like Pasadena would have
like how many kids were in your
graduating class do you remember I don't
remember so I went to Cerritos High
School and I remember coming to Capital
and I'm like dude this is [__] like
it's ghetto just saying it's [__] up
it's like this is not it's like it's
like a third world country man today's
video is brought to you by Sunday all
right check this out what is this it's
beautiful beautiful fertilizer for your
home it's pretty awesome because if
you're anyone like me and you don't like
to do too much thinking about all the
lawn care that's going to be happening
during Springtime everything's gonna be
grown and blooming and you want to make
sure you have the most greenest
beautiful lawn on the Block well let's
take the thinking out of this and we can
put our trust into the hands of Sunday
because they got us covered so all you
need is to grab your garden hose plug it
into this bad boy right here and then
this part connects to come back to the
back right here
like that and then you just go ahead and
start spreading your lawn
and they are replenished with me
and they get really really good
fertilizer and they start blooming and
then now you could be like
check out my lawn I got a beautiful lot
huh Sunday is easy and affordable some
lawn care services cost more than
fifteen hundred dollars a year but
Sunday's full season plan just start at
109 Sunday is everything you need to get
the lawn you dreamed of this spring go
to getsunday.com off the Record and
enter your address to get a customized
plan created just for your lawn and
Sunday is offering our listeners 20 Off
full season plans start at just a
hundred and nine dollars and you can get
20 off when you go to getsunday.com off
the Record at checkout that's 20 off
your custom plan at getsunday.com off
the Record yeah yeah but I'm sure
cerno's High School's problem was
[__] crazy I got I got a slightly
cringy story that I know you guys are
gonna dunk yeah though right foreign
like find yourself type [__]
we all were man yeah we all were I was
the dude that showed us it was funny in
an all-white tux and a cane that looks
dope what like Kingpin pimp yeah but the
funny thing is I look back and I cringe
at those hilariously because I still had
braces oh it was just a funny look
you must have felt tight in what you
were wearing I'm the time I was proud
enough to just try to be different
yeah you would look like a orthodontic
patient that died and came back as an
angel yeah yeah like I look at it now at
the time I think I felt like kind of
tired
going all the way to like go to Friar
Tux get a white tux and then also find a
cane That's white and [__] that ball
should go to get a white tub that's what
I'm saying it's like I was like proud of
that in one sense but every single time
I go back home and I see like that photo
I'm like this is a [__] loser dude
I'm the only one in White in my group
yeah yeah for sure I never wanted to go
to any of those but the only ones that I
thought was cool was uh Sadie Hawkins
because you have to dress the same yeah
that's always yeah that was cool because
you have to match right and then it
could be anything
I was supposed to ask the guys yeah
girls ask guys so that was also funny in
high school yeah we had it we called it
girl date at our school girl date yeah
just because the girls had to ask but it
was Sadie Hawkins and did you get asked
yeah of course you did how did she ask
was it fancy or just like no I think it
was it was just cute and nice probably
had like a nice little letter saying
that I was a cool friend or something
she was really nice girl bro I was so
stupid when I got asked to go to prom my
um my answer was man I ain't gonna pay
money for that scam
it's right though
well cause you gotta buy all it's like
hundreds of dollars and then you have
the corsage boutonniere yeah in my head
I'm like girl if you want to dance let's
go to the beach
if you want to dance Joe reading all his
mercenary magazines and so it's excuse
me
I don't want no scam
mercenaries you know what I will say
though dude yeah
um going up going to my prom I remember
uh was a sick just such a great
adolescent experience you know what I
mean uh I was it was also with like you
know
the girl got away kind of thing and she
went to a different school so like even
asking her to come to my prom was
already like it wasn't one of those
things that you have to do at campus or
anything where like there's all the
Social Circles it was a very private
thing because I was just asking a friend
from a different campus but I still had
the nerves because I was like oh [__]
it's like prom and are kind of into this
chick right did you do like a big type
of ask you're not able to make it like
into a thing no no she was always so
cool and just like a a homey type of
friend yeah um that we just had a really
long friendship for for a couple years
and I just kind of like asked her I was
like Hey like would you be down to like
I've always been down to like you know
hang out with you in this type of way
blah blah ask her to go to prom she was
like yeah I'm super down and I remember
just having the butterflies and it was
really really fun and at the end of the
night uh when I eventually I took her
back to her car and stuff like that she
just gave me a kiss on the cheek and I
just remember not [__] forgetting
that for like the whole summer wow you
know what I mean so just wanted
but you better you better believe it was
one of those things where it's like you
you hold your cool you hold your cool
you know she leaves she's [__] gone
and you already know the first person I
was calling is like my cousin
smack then though that was like when you
had a kiss from a girl it would just go
Boop and it just starts going all over
your
[__] freeze dude you cannot compute
the crazy thing is when I went to uh so
we didn't have problems but I would go
to promise for girls I was dating and
whatever school they were going multiple
problems yeah hell yeah man
stacked schedule
um Bishop Ahmad and then um I thought I
was like my hair was all cool because I
had blonde spikes this is the Year 2001.
everyone had it I thought it was so cool
no dude it was even worse like uh we
went we met up with like her friend
group and uh her friend group was like
like in the Asian kind of pockets of
these high schools and like the 66 Asian
girlfriend groups are massive right and
they got like 20 something deep all like
girls and then their dudes are all from
different places too and then all these
guys was all like Filipino dudes like me
but they were like cornrows everybody
cornrows cornrows cornrows and I was
like
damn I ain't [__]
because like I'd even think of that
you're like I'm Cloud Strife I got
bleach tips and I know and my [__] looks
so old compared to that because like
they're all like they look like today's
like hip hop MTV yeah but they're like
Filipino like me and I just look like I
felt so inspired I was like damn dude I
was he from Long Beach and you're from
sgv they were from everywhere they and
they were just did you bust a move that
night and let them know dude and that's
another thing I didn't because your
confidence no because that was the first
night that I had ever seen somebody
freestyle dance oh so you were about to
learn because I was like yo I'm a brand
of smoke everybody there was no other B
boys because I don't want to be the
first because I thought like why would
you wanna b-boy when everyone's wearing
tux yeah and then there were these two
dudes uh one guy his name his name's
Ashton and the other guy's name is Ray
and I've been friends with Ray for a
while but I've never seen him dance and
then they just started doing this weird
like like stuff and everybody was like
whoa and then like so was I and I'm like
I don't even know what that is is it
crumping no they were just like
Freestyle like it was like early 2000s
just freestyle dance it's just like
whatever like no form but just like
super cool these two guys and they were
had matching Brown like like kind of
looking vintage Earth Tone suits yeah
and I was like this is so beyond my [__]
and I couldn't even break that and I was
like I'm not even that's so much cooler
than what I do yeah and then I was like
bro how do you I went up to Ray I'm like
bro how do you learn how to dance like
that and he goes edger millennium
and I was like what the hell is that I
was like what is Edger Millennium it'd
be such a great story if like the birth
of you jumping onto your head was from
there you're wanting to kill myself
attempt it and like that was the birth
of like you foreign
but I didn't know that that was two
things oh is it Edge or Millennia and I
was like what the hell is an edger
Millennium
so then it turns out like thumbs up no
results and so I've been friends with
Ray for like maybe like a year and I
just never knew that he like got down
like that I didn't even know how to
define it Rey's Ray Bossa by the way oh
and then uh Ashton he ended up being
like this super famous fashion designer
for like uh Black Eyed Peas and like
William like he's like he was on like
next in fashion or something and got
second place like he's just a trench
massive fashion designer now and uh and
they were like the first two people I
saw like just they had the corn rolls
they're very forward dude yeah they were
and I think they were maybe no Ray I
think was already out by then but I
think Ashton was still straight at the
time but I was like dude I want to be
like that okay gay
so I don't know if you ever went to
these dances but I don't know how these
high school kids pulled it off but they
would get like Halls rented out like in
in the community right and these are the
ones I like going to because it wasn't
just the same people at my high school
but also a lot of fights would go down
because it would just be from different
high schools with the AAA dances yes
like that you ever been to the AAA dance
no is that like the key
I don't even remember which clubs pulled
it off but I remember there were always
gang fights there yeah yeah but they
were but that was like a place where you
can actually meet girls from different
high schools right it's like Community
socials in a way yeah but they they
booked like the Elks Lodge or they
booked like the AAA Center the Chinese
Cultural Center and then they would
throw these parties there and it felt
more cool than school because they
weren't like those chaperones there was
a security guard and some stuff but that
was it I don't know how those how they
did those either yeah yeah but they were
like 16 17 year olds pulling these
things off and I was like those were
really fun because then they had like no
control with the like the DJs doesn't
have to censor their [__] so then it
would it would feel like I'm at a 18
plus Club yeah the prom was always that
after parties you'd go to prom to say
that you went to prom do the dress do
that thing for like a good hour and then
everybody ends up leaving yeah I didn't
know that was the thing you know
that
I wonder if like growing up too early
and like going raving at like 14 and
stuff kind of messed up the prom
experience for me
because I'm like you want to see what a
real party's like that's that's next
level bro because a lot of my friends
were dropping e and [__] at the at proms
or like at school dances dude you sell
it there and then you would go to the
radio they were they were trying to
throw it like a rave yeah oh dang do you
know that one Usher song where he goes
and I'm gonna be all right tonight you
don't have to call girl so that music
video it's like at the LA Bonaventure or
whatever on the tops like in the angle
you see like a bunch of people standing
on the balconies that's my actual
banquet from senior year that's cool
it just happened to be taking place like
uh a few floors above where they were
filming it so they let us like look over
and like watch the whole like while they
were filming it you were there Usher
Yeah that's [__] cool [__] one of
the sickest music videos ever I should
have stayed in school with you I mean we
couldn't we couldn't like meet them we
couldn't meet anybody but we can't
hey B2K came to our school but then I
wasn't allowed to your performance
that's tight how come you weren't loud
because I got in trouble for what
probably some stupid [__] bad boy man
anyway we just want to give a big Hail
to the King before we end this video
hey are you really scared I was gonna
bring that photo out
right out of all the people in here Ryan
would be the one that's like hey check
this out about like hitting a tip for
something but I'm like I'm not gonna do
that too
[Music]
laughs